I don't care what Plantation I end up on
I'm straight staging a Revolt in this
Hells yeah we have lot a
Lot B
for three dollars
[Music]
a five five dollars going once twice
three times sold laude goes to the man
and the black hat
I mean good yeah I'm glad I didn't get
sold because I don't want to be owned by
another human being whoever buys me they
better kill me the first day I'm gonna
go buck wild on the whole operation next
one get up on up there now
oh it's okay
six dollars on lot a seven dollars eight
nine nine dollar going once twice three
times sold
okay well you have to buy that dude it's
a no-brainer I mean that guy's a huge
massive individuals that's two of me
anybody would buy him I'd buy that dude